I hear things are crazier than ever
can you kind of touch on that you don't
get to spend time meeting the character
setting the tone you know understanding
that the dynamics of the relationships
those kind of things so you have to hit
the ground running you know you have to
get straight into plot and what the
writers did this year which I thought
was really bold was that they they they
flipped everything you know in the first
season of daredevil Matt Murdock and
Wilson Fisk don't meet until the ninth
episode they're probably caught from the
same cloth and that's an immensely
frightening prospect for someone like
Matt Murdock when I finally get out of
this cage I will dismantle the lives of
the two amateurs mr. Murdock and
Franklin Percy know people are getting
emotionally beat up and physically beat
up it's pretty pretty wild do you think
they could take down the defenders
Wilson Fisk
can do anything he puts his mind to yeah
hey everybody we got a whole bunch of
new daredevil to talk about I love that
quote could the kingpin defeat the
defenders well he could do anything he
puts his mind to and even though this is
mostly gonna be a daredevil season 3
video I will address kingpin
defenders season 2 stuff because I do
think that he will become the big bad of
the Marvel Netflix series in a way that
the hand was the big bat of defenders
season 1 so if you're brand new to the
channel be sure to subscribe to get
everything so Vincent D'Onofrio has been
on the set we have the first couple of
pictures from them filming so what it
looks like they're ramping up for at
least when they're filming these scenes
here is the trial of the kingpin so as
with every season that Matt Murdock or
foggy appear in you have some sort of
courtroom scene like they had the trial
of the Punisher during daredevil season
2 it makes sense that if they're gonna
be doing part of the born-again
storyline maybe some of the Murdock
paper storyline that they have some
scenes with the kingpin actually facing
charges in a courtroom trial but here a
couple of key things and this all goes
into the comic book stories that they're
doing Matt Murdock his identity as the
daredevil and those two separate
identities in public so there's Matt
Murdock attorney at law then you have
the devil of Hell's Kitchen
so if Matt Murdock is out of commission
at least at first then both of those
people will be
and you have to explain that like why is
it Matt Murdock around he's a key figure
in the case against the kingpin who's
been rotting in prison this whole time
but here's the thing is that Vincent
D'Onofrio was quoted as saying that
they've done a lot of really cool comic
book stuff that fans have been hoping
for for a while which is where he's
talking about born-again stuff but
there's opportunity to do more meaning
that it's not going to be exactly like
it was in the comics it's gonna feel
like born again with some other comic
book stuff and just follow up on
everything that they set up during
daredevil season 2 so during the course
of season 2 kingpin vowed to take down
Matt Murdock not the daredevil he
doesn't know that daredevil is Matt
Murdock yet but he learns that during
the born-again arc and then during the
Murdock papers arc he's actually sitting
in prison trying to broker a deal to get
out with the FBI and regain his fortune
which is why I think that they're doing
a little bit of that Murdock paper
storyline so based on the scenes with
these protesters that they're filming
like they want him to go back to prison
it sounds like he either beats the
charges because Matt Murdock isn't
around or he finds a way to broker a
deal and he's just in the process of
trying to get out and that just takes
place over the course of the season like
as of right now kingpin is not
comic-book kingpin yet he's not that
powerful so I think over the course of
season 3 we'll see that happen he'll
slowly consolidate his power use all the
confusion from the end of defenders in
the deaths of the hand members to steal
as much money in territory from them so
wouldn't it be funny if it felt like
daredevil season 3 was more about
kingpin than about daredevil like
usually daredevil will always be the
hero of any title that he's in but if
they make you root for the kingpin that
would just be brilliant like him slowly
rising to power Scarface style the world
is mine DeLuna I'll be a little
protection cruel wasn't cheap nor
shouldn't be your cash is almost gone
anything you need for the rest of your
stay
you'll be dipping into the reserves into
Vanessa's protection but the really
interesting way that he does that during
the Murdock papers which is basically
what that story is is him getting out of
prison using some fake evidence and some
trickery with the FBI all the members of
the government that he has to deal with
all the different agents
they all think that he's a total scumbag
so the brilliant thing that he does is
he drags his case into the court of
public opinion so he makes his appeal
through the newspaper so it was through
Ben in the comics but because kingpin
killed him at the end of season one they
might change a little bit of that but it
becomes a very fake new situation where
kingpin uses his celebrity in the court
of public opinion to win his way into a
deal with the FBI and it's all based on
a bluff he has something that he calls
the Murdock papers he can definitively
prove that Matt Murdock is the daredevil
which is something that he had already
learned during the born-again arc so he
knew that Matt Murdock was daredevil but
now he had told the FBI that he had
definitive proof he called it the
Murdock papers but what happened is his
bullseye was also imprisoned with
kingpin and he wanted to get out too so
everybody wants to get their hands on
what they think is the evidence against
Matt Murdock because he's the person
that put all them behind bars so if you
could prove that the attorney that put
you behind bars is actually a vigilante
who he himself breaks the law on a
regular basis it will void all the
convictions getting them out of prison
so it sounds like however they decided
to born again or the Murdock papers
that's one of the easy ways for the
kingpin to beat all the charges he
doesn't have to prove that he's innocent
he just has to prove that Matt is guilty
of being the daredevil but the kingpin
is a master at playing people against
each other so I think the real fun of
the season is gonna be watching him
manipulate Karen foggy and Matt to
either give each other up without
realizing it like Karen Paige has this
really dirty history that she doesn't
want to get out people were threatening
to blackmail her back during season one
now obviously there's a little bit of
comic stuff that goes into there but
they've changed her character quite a
bit so that could come back to haunt her
during season three it wind up being
some of the things that lead to the
kingpin learning Matt's secret identity
but this is all assuming that he's come
back but at least for the first part of
the season or the first couple of
episodes it sounds like the team will be
separated because Matt will be healing
at this convent the rest of team
daredevil will be back in the city doing
their regular day-to-day so let me know
in the comments how do you think that
the kingpin is going to get out of
prison and consolidate his power just
remember that Matt was responsible for
putting him
behind bars in if people learned that
he's the daredevil it will void that
conviction and to the hand is
effectively dead so they have all this
power all these minions that the kingpin
can swoop in in steel like you work for
me now
I'm the kingpin I control this city but
I know everybody wants to know when are
they gonna drop the new season so just a
reminder Jessica Jones is coming in
March Heroes for Hire has already
finished filming so they'll drop that
next probably during the summer and then
daredevil season 3 will either drop at
the beginning of the fall or sometime in
early winter like around November but
they haven't confirmed those dates yet
it's just that they're up to the point
now where they release three Netflix
series per year so who knows what'll
happen in 2019 but I don't know that
they're gonna do another defender series
for at least two more years but we got
all that stuff going on with the new
Disney streaming service and then
pulling their content from Netflix so if
we learn anything about that if it has
anything to do with the Marvel Netflix
series I'll be sure to add it to a video
but just leave all your bonus video
requests in the comments below but if
you didn't see there's a new round of
that Infinity Gauntlet giveaway going on
right now all you have to do to enter is
just be subscriber leave a comment on
the video and there'll be a new black
panther trailer on Monday so I'll
announce a winner when I post that click
here for more daredevil season 3 and
click here for more new infinity war
thank you so much for watching everybody
stay awesome I'll see you guys tonight